kikou les boys and girls vous êtes
chauds déjà le troisième toute hausse de
la deûle en mode dance vous êtes prêts
j'appelle les boys
allez c'est parti on démarre avec leur
tournée agacé musique on se retourne on
avance on est sexy et là nouveau passé
vous tous ensemble la pâquerette de
l'amour haine par deux balles frais
petit elfe rykiel frétille elle veut
vivre la drogue vive mère d un l et clôt
une fois quelle vie qu'est ce qu'elle
fait et bien dense c'est la sexy sexy
des 1 tw est sexy sexy sexy et ensuite
qu'est ce qu'elle fait là pâquerettes
elle est heureuse de vivre alors eh ben
elle veut séduire le ciel droit à
l'amour les boys alors s'il est où là où
de l'amour way hula-hoop de l'amour
allez on continue et on continue et le
classique je m'offre ou là où le biais
de la cage où le couple ou qu'il est
vilain tu lui lâche qu'il y aura
quelqu'un je ne sais pas
1dans sera professionnel emmenées bien
sûr qu'il pourrait remplacer un grand
artiste comme moi maintenant c'est la
salle un motard des jeunes tarnaises de
nouveaux pas pour un motard des huit
participants aux castes hagen et qui
recule au cast hagen ou pire qu aux
cartes hagen et le deuxième pas tapas
tombe à jade évite le pata des honteux
tu as entre page 14
j'ai mis ma part j'aurais imaginé que
sous ce choeur velu et musclés se cache
un artiste danseur mokhtar mais fréty le
plaisir et l'honneur d'accepter ce tuto
avec toi tu attends bouffon pièces et
sur place luc nous fait mokhtar
aujourd'hui on va tous faire la moutarde
m alors c'est parti pour la montée d'eze
m
laborde ardennes
bravo
la drogue
l'amour retardé
billets les lois j'ai été forcée
troisième tuto ce brave homme antar
bravo mais boys et bravo chez vous je
vous donne rendez vous le savez pour un
quatrième tut hausse de la deûle en mode
and buy